continue de traiter la culture et
l'histoire sous le prisme masculin qui
nous est présenté comme la norme et
l'ambition de féministes in the city
c'est de montrer qu'il ya aussi une
autre histoire qui est encore à
conquérir
l'histoire des femmes et du féminisme je
suis julie marange est la co fondatrice
et dirigeante de féminisme the city
asséné en 2018 notamment dans le cadre
de de nos études à sciences po paris
puisque la cofondatrice et moi même
avons avions donc pour ambition de
sensibiliser aux inégalités femmes
hommes mais de manière assez ludique et
également de démystifier le féminisme
qui a un mot encore très tabou en france
et dans plein de pays
dans la plupart des pays européens est
notre première visite street art et
féminisme est donc née en mars 2018 en
fait ça on s'est d'abord intéressé au
street art de la butte aux cailles dans
le 13ème arrondissement et notamment à
l'artiste mystique qui a beaucoup
d'oeuvres dans ce quartier de paris et
en regardant simplement dans le quartier
où s'est rendu compte qu'il y avait
énormément d'oeuvre de street artistes
femmes et féministe ça a vraiment servi
de porte d'entrée pour parler de tous
les enjeux liés à l'égalité
femmes-hommes de l'égalité salariale à
la maternité en passant par les
violences faites aux femmes
alors attention parce qu'on n'a pas
l'habitude de réaliser femme subissait
un homme et qui correspond à tous les
critères attendus dans la vérité dans
notre cité
[Musique]
beaucoup de femmes street artistes vont
coller parce que c'est plus rapide parce
que si on doit venir la nuit ou se
dépêcher de récupérer tout le matériel
ça va beaucoup plus vite avec des
collages qu'on peut glisser dans son sac
et disparaître discrètement
[Musique]
base j'étais pas du tout féministe c'est
vraiment en allant en angleterre et en
étudiant en angleterre je suis passé de
ma première année universitaire à
l'université de baffes pas du tout
féministe à ma dernière année
universitaire où j'étais donc présidente
de l'association féministe c'est un
sujet dont il fallait parler en fait on
a énormément de visites guidées
on a énormément d'aspects culturelles
qui sont traitées mais pas sous le
prisme de l'égalité femmes hommes et du
féminisme et en fait on a traité la
culture et l'histoire et on continue de
traiter la culture et l'histoire sous le
prisme masculin qui nous est présenté
comme la norme et l'ambition de
féministes in the city c'est de montrer
qu'il ya aussi une autre histoire qui
est encore à conquérir
l'histoire des femmes et du féminisme
il ya énormément c'est un gros syndrome
de l'imposteur hills il ya également des
billets sexiste du qui font que les
femmes ne se ne se retrouve pas dans les
galeries et on avait d'ailleurs les
guerrilla girls qui est donc un
collectif de deux militantes qui disait
que justement il ya 95% de nu qui sont
représentées dans les musées qui sont
des femmes mais que seulement 5% des
artistes exposés sont des femmes dont il
ya un vrai problème de représentation
des femmes dans les milieux et dans les
espaces culturels et c'est à la fois
dans les musées comme d'orsay le musée
du louvre etc mais aussi dans la rue
dans le street art
c'est un combat que mènent tous les
jours et qui est super important surtout
en ce moment et je trouve que j'ai aussi
interview décliné sous diverses formes
le danemark sic elle j'ai trouvé ça
hyper intéressant il ya plein de choses
que je ne suis pas de souliers donc ça
m'a permis de badens avoir encore plus
et 2
le maître un autre regard sur justement
le strip
il ya une majorité de femmes qui vient
faire les visites
cécile est joli disque est à peu près 85
% de femmes et 15 % d'hommes ça serait
génial de pouvoir toucher en fait les
personnes qui ont peur du féminisme qui
déteste ça mais pour le moment c'est
plus des personnes qui sont curieuses et
où déjà acquise à la cause
dans tous les cas même si on n'est pas
féministe ou engagés pour l'égalité ou
qu'on n'y connaît rien ça peut toujours
être une manière de réfléchir à ces
sujets là c'est des visites qui sont
très interactive est en fait l'objectif
c'est pas de dire voilà il ya ça il ya
six lycées comme ça qu'il faut penser
mais c'est de montrer qu'il ya plusieurs
féminisme qui existe qui a plusieurs
mouvements qu'il ya plusieurs manières
de penser et que vraiment les personnes
finalement et des informations des
informations qu'ils soient objectives et
puis se construira un esprit critique
[Musique]